- All right, we always like to wrap things
up with something fun and uplifting.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music sting)
(crowd cheering)
Y'all know how much I appreciate
and love my musical
director, Jason Halbert.
I'm so happy to have him in my corner.
I would have no career without him,
but I'm not the only person
that he has encouraged
over the years, there's many of us.
In fact, he's been supporting
an author in Nashville
and she's just published her first book
called "In The Shadow Garden",
let's say hi to Liz Parker everybody.
(crowd cheering)
Hi, Liz.
What's up?
So it's great to see you.
So congrats on the book.
- Thank you so much.
You're holding it, it's-
(Kelly laughing)
Thank you.
- I know, it's cool when
it's, like, tangible, right?
And you do something and it
comes out and, like, people-
it's so cool. Yeah, that's a cool place.
So you say that Jason was pivotal, right,
in pushing you to do this?
- Yeah, so I've been
writing for, like, 12 years.
This is my first published book,
but it's my sixth book
and Jason actually read my
second book and liked it,
(Liz and crowd laughing)
and provided feedback and
he and his entire family
have been so supportive of my writing
and so enthusiastic ever since.
And that kind of support is, just,
it keeps you going when you're trying
to break into an industry like publishing.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- I'm so grateful.
- Yeah, and the cool thing about Jason is,
he is, like, super honest,
like he's supportive
but he is encouraging and, like, honest.
And that's good, though.
You need those people.
That's why he's helped
me my entire career.
But can you tell us more about the book?
- Yeah, so, people tell
you to write what you know,
and I know a lot about
trauma and gardening,
(Kelly laughing)
and so I thought what
if something beautiful
could grow from our pain?
And that became "In The Shadow Garden".
So it's like kind of in
the vein of practical magic
where it's witchy but it's not scary,
and it follows three
generations of empathic witches
who can heal their neighbor's pain,
and they bury it in their garden.
And then there's like a rival family
that has magical bourbon that
lets you forget a memory.
So it asks the question "is
it better to heal over time
or to forget what caused you pain?".
And I'm just so excited to see it, like,
in bookstores and on
bookshelves as a real book.
- Yeah, I'm, I'm excited.
I wanna see the movie.
That's what I, I mean I like the book.
I- your Mind doesn't have a budget,
but that would make a great
movie, is all I'm saying.
Oh, there is a movie?
(Liz laughing)
- So a really great
film production company
actually read the book and
fell in love with the book,
and before it was even published
they optioned the rights
for film and series.
- What?!
(crowd cheering)
- [Liz] On the screen someday.
- This is incredible, that's
incredible. Congratulations.
I know I was listening
to you tell the story
and I was like "well, I
can't wait to read the book,
but I also wanna see it".
Thanks Liz, and congratulations
again. This is incredible.
(crowd cheering)
I'm liking your post right now.
(ding)
And at this point, we
usually give our guest
a check for $1,000 from
our season-long partner
Pilot Pen, makers of G2, the go-to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
But today, Liz wants to
help someone in the audience
pursue their passions with
a little unexpected cash.
So one of you has $1,000
check securely taped
beneath your chairs, so look.
(crowd cheering)
(drumroll)
Y'all aren't looking hard enough.
Are y'all like this at Christmas?
(upbeat music sting)
(crowd cheering)
Yeah! (laughing)
What's your name? Where are you from?
- Hi, I'm Ashley Hart.
I'm originally from Texas,
but I live in Los Angeles now
for about a year.
- There's some Texas here
today, y'all representing,
I like this audience.
Well, how will you use the money?
- I'm in law school. Don't cry.
And, so it's very expensive and it's-
I come from a low-income family,
so this is just like
a really big blessing.
Thank you so much.
(crowd cheering)
- Wow. Well, you know what?
That is really amazing and I, I feel like,
opportunity like that should
not be taken from anyone,
so I'm gonna give you five grand, too,
to help you, for law school.
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you.
- That's really incredible.
You gotta keep going at it.
Don't let the money thing stop you.
Keep going for it, all right?
- Thank you so much.
- Yeah, gotta help my Texas girl out.
All right, well thank you so
much to all our guests today,
Eddie Redmayne, Emily
Deschanel, Dara Yu, John Indigo,
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, try and change it.